well guys if you've been following me on
facebook which you should facebook.com
slash Chris Duckman I announced that in
2013 I was going to try to start
reviewing video games because I kind of
mentioned a few times in my videos that
I enjoy video games I mentioned that I
like the Resident Evil games in my
Resident Evil review of the film from
the NES to the ps3 I have been a gamer
and I have wanted to review games I just
haven't really had the opportunity to it
just never really struck me as something
I really wanted to do until most
recently I was just like you know what I
play games all the time and I know a lot
of you guys like to play games too so
why not start talking about games more
often on my channel I won't be able to
review them as often as I do movies
obviously they're more expensive and I
don't play as many games as I watch
movies but I'd like to try to review
games more often starting with Batman
Arkham Asylum and Batman Arkham City cue
the awesome intro so before I get into
talking about these games let me give
you a little history of myself as a
gamer I've had Nintendo Power
subscriptions GamePro subscriptions I
currently have a subscription to Game
Informer I read i GN reviews all the
time I look up Game Rankings calm news
about games because I am actually a
pretty big gamer and I really love games
Batman Arkham Asylum and Batman Arkham
City are two of the best comic book
games ever made in fact it's a rarity to
even find those that are actually good
almost all superhero games suck in so
many different ways if you were a gamer
in the 90s like myself all I have to do
is say Superman 64 and you just put your
head in your hands
let me tell you a quick story in 1999
when Superman 64 came out I rented that
game from blockbuster I was 11 years old
alright and I put that game in the
system and Superman just goes like this
all of a sudden that just starts flying
and then what happens all I gotta say is
two words and you hardcore gamers from
the 90s know exactly what I'm talking
about the Rings Superman flies through
rings forever and it's horrible and I
was 11 years old and I was like what is
this is this supposed to be this bad am
I supposed to be able to crash through
the ground come into this black world
hear weird splashing sounds and get
completely stuck in this glitch of a
game no you're not supposed to because
superhero games had more they had more
to offer I told you that to tell you
this one of the reasons these games were
so cool for me is because I've never
played such an extensive expansive fun
superhero game that wasn't just a fun
game to play it actually had good
gameplay and it got the character that
it was portraying in both of these games
is essentially the Joker having a giant
scheme in which he puts Batman through
all these various tests but one of the
cool things about it is it kind of
sidestepped the cliched have to have one
or two villains per game thing it had
like all of them in one game the second
one had some more of them that weren't
in the first game because it took place
in Arkham Asylum so he had an excuse to
have all these different villains in one
place the first one felt very
claustrophobic because it was all in
that prison
it felt really confined and you really
felt that in the game the combat system
in the game started out very simple I
was a little disappointed it was just a
button masher you know a lot of square
square square square square but it
changed and evolved over time it got
harder it got more difficult it actually
had some strategy to it it got more
challenging sometimes you had to counter
other people's moves sometimes the
enemies would have like a stun baton
sometimes they would have shield and you
would have to figure out ways to get
around them and so it wasn't just a
pointless button masher you actually had
to use strategy and I really liked that
another really cool thing about this
game is that they have little stealth
areas in which Batman has to take out a
whole bunch of guys without being seen
because they have guns and let's face it
Batman doesn't kill and so you don't
want to have to come up against like 12
guys that have guns because he's gonna
die almost instantly and it was kind of
Metal Gear Solid ish he had to actually
sneak up on guys and chokehold him and
take him out it was a lot of fun to do
that as Batman that's one of the coolest
novelties about these games is being
Batman jumping into a giant horde of
thugs and just wiping them all out one
of my nitpicks with both of these games
is that the difficulty levels seem to
vary a lot I played on normal for both
of them and then certain sections would
be challenging and there would be
certain things about them I was okay I
understand how to do this I can figure
this out but then you would just walk
into a room and there'd be like 15 guys
with guns and you have to stealth all of
them but they have night vision and
sniper rifles and how in the world you
supposed to do that and that would be
stuck on these little spots for so long
sometimes and it got kind of annoying
and if you remember the spider-man and
the spider-man 2 games that came out on
GameCube and ps2 back in the day
the first one was very confined kind of
it was a city but you couldn't really do
as much it was a straightforward
objective in spider-man 2 it was like a
free roaming game you could swing around
the entire city it was awesome but then
there were all these other little added
objectives like maybe over here someone
is robbing a bank maybe you have to
deliver a pizza over there because
you're Peter Parker still from Batman
Arkham Asylum to Arkham City it did
something very similar it became very
free roaming in Arkham City you could
fly over the entire city maybe someone
was getting mugged maybe there was a
robbery taking place maybe there was a
murder victim found and all of that is
fun and it definitely adds to an
expansive feel and kind of makes for a
better game I have this OCD with myself
as a gamer where I have to just know
what is my objective right now I have to
go in there each little room and collect
each item and do everything so I can get
a hundred percent that's like my OCD and
so when a game comes along as a free
roaming game and I'm supposed to go
after the Joker right now then all of a
sudden there's like a phone call over
there that I have to answer and then
there's someone being mugged it's it's
like my brain was exploding and I
couldn't focus I was like oh my god no
no my OCD needs me to be able to
accomplish the main objective right now
but I can't because with all these side
objectives it's not a negative to the
game at all in fact it actually is
really incredible how much stuff you can
do in this game even when you beat the
main story there's still more stuff to
do which is really cool but for someone
who is an OCD gamer like myself where I
have to have everything and accomplish
it so I can move on to the next thing it
gets a little tiring sometimes overall
these are incredible games they truly
are games that got Batman right it was
like a combination of the nolan feel
with the batman the animated series feel
which my opinion is the two best
incarnations of batman we've ever seen
past the comic page had kevin conroy the
voice of Batman Mark Hamill has Joker
that was just so great to hear it so
these games got the tone of Batman right
the feel of the character and they were
just a really fun time great graphics
terrific visuals really great sound fun
gameplay it wasn't anything remarkably
like groundbreaking there is a lot of
button mashing to it but there was some
nice strategy to it as well and some
stealth missions that really made it
seem like it wasn't just your standard
button masher beat up all these thugs
and then get out of there now when I
review movies I review them based on
letter
raids when I think about games though I
always kind of think out of 10 that's
just how my brain works so I'm going to
do out of 10 for video games and for
both of these games I'm going to give
them 8.5 out of 10 to me it felt like
playing one game to the next it was
almost like just one big experience that
worked and benefited on each other so
guys I'm going to be doing my best to
review more games for you guys that come
out I'm going to be reviewing the new
Metal Gear Rising game that comes out
soon and Dead Space 3 that comes out
soon or played 1 & 2 really enjoyed
those games I'm a big Metal Gear fan if
you didn't know the four Metal Gear
Solid games as a whole are what I call
my favorite video game
that's just they're incredible so guys
let me know what you think do you want
me to review more video games I will try
to do that I want to do more new release
titles I'm not going to be able to
review as many because they're so
expensive
also it's not like I'm gonna buy a game
that I know is just god-awful you know
but I'm going to try to do my best to
tell you guys about cool games that are
out there and try to talk to you in some
way in in shape or form that actually
makes sense about video games thanks a
lot for watching guys and as always if
you like this and you can click right
here and get stuck my next
[Music]
Oh